SARA ROBINSON: With almost
500 sessions at Next 2018,
it's understandable that you
couldn't get to them all.
So if you didn't see my talk,
From Zero to ML on Google Cloud
Platform, then stay tuned
because here's the rewind.
[MUSIC PLAYING]
Maybe you've never built a
machine learning model before.
Or maybe you're a
hardcore ML expert.
No matter your
level of experience,
we've got something for
you on Google Cloud.
In this talk, I covered our
spectrum of machine learning
offerings, from
products targeted
towards application
developers with little
or no machine
learning experience
to tools for folks with more
ML expertise The talk covered
three of our cloud machine
learning products--
Machine Learning APIs,
Auto ML, and ML Engine.
Let's get a quick
taste of each section,
starting with Machine
Learning APIs.
Our ML APIs make it easy to add
machine learning to your app
with a single REST API request.
No ML expertise or
training data required.
We've got five APIs to help
you with common ML tasks--
analyzing images, analyzing
video, converting audio
to text, analyzing text,
and translating text
into over 100 languages.
I highlighted our Vision
and Natural Language APIs
with live demos, showing how
you can try these APIs directly
in the browser.
Then, we had a cameo from
Nick Hasty, director of R&D
at Giphy, an app for searching
and sharing millions of GIFs.
Nick shared how Giphy is using
the Vision and Natural Language
APIs to optimize Giphy's
search and GIF tagging.
Nick showed us that the
ML APIs are a great way
to get up and running
with ML quickly.
But what if you need
to customize them
with your own data?
That's where our newest addition
to Cloud Machine Learning
comes in, Cloud AutoML.
Announced in beta
at Next, AutoML
lets you train Vision, Natural
Language, and Translation
models with your own data.
No model code required.
In the AutoML section, I showed
live demos of each variants
in the AutoML UI.
Starting with Vision,
I demoed a model
that can detect the type
of cloud in an image.
While you could use the
Vision API to tell you
an image has a
cloud, we wouldn't
expect it to identify the
scientific name of a cloud.
This model can classify five
different types of clouds.
AutoML Natural
Language lets you build
custom text classification
models trained on your own text
data.
I showed a demo using a data
set from the nonprofit Donors
Choose, which
matches teachers who
need resources for
their classroom
with interested donors.
With AutoML NL, I built a model
to categorize need requests
from teachers into categories
so that donors can easily
be matched with projects
they're interested in.
AutoML Translate lets you build
domain specific translation
models for translating
industry specific jargon
and linguistic nuances.
There are many instances
where the Cloud Translation
API will work just fine.
But certain cases require
a translation model trained
on your own custom data.
For example, let's say I see
the following error message
on my machine.
I can summarize it as the
driver is not working.
But what if I need to
translate this summary?
In our case, we know
this refers to software.
But taken out of context,
the translation is ambiguous.
It could be referring
to a broken golf club--
the driver club isn't working.
The same sentence
could also refer
to a taxi driver
who is on strike,
and therefore not working.
A base model wouldn't know
which domain this referred to,
and this is where a custom
model comes in handy.
I showed a live demo of AutoML
Translate using data provided
by our customer we localize.
I'm incredibly
excited about AutoML
because it makes custom
models accessible to anyone,
regardless of
their ML expertise.
But there are cases where
you have a custom task
and need more control over
the type of model you're using
and the inputs to that model.
That brings us to the
third section of the talk--
Cloud ML Engine.
ML Engine is a managed platform
for training and serving
your own custom ML models.
It supports models built
with TensorFlow, Keras,
Scikit-learn, and XGBoost.
You can leverage ML Engine's
GPUs and TPUs to train models,
and you can deploy your models
to ML Engine for serving.
To show ML Engine,
my teammate Zack Akil
came on stage to
share a live demo.
Zack and I each built
models independently
to accomplish the same task.
I built one in TensorFlow,
and he built one
using Scikit-learn.
We used ML Engine to
serve them, and Zack
showed how easy it is to
build a front end that
calls different
versions of your model,
even if they were built with
entirely different frameworks
and dependencies.
Well, that's it.
The talk covered
a lot of material.
And I hope it gave you an idea
of the variety of ML offerings
we have on Google Cloud.
If you'd like to
see the full talk,
check out the link in
the description below.
And don't forget to subscribe
to the Cloud YouTube
channel for more great
Next Rewind content.
Thanks for watching.
[MUSIC PLAYING]